[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's your boy
[Music]
you're about to get caught
[Music]
[Music]
didn't come to my birthday party but
they all found time to go fight the
warriors
check it out
check it out
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
watch me watch me dance
[Music]
watch me dance
i know i get it eventually
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage gearbox entertainment's chief
communication officer dan hewitt
hey everybody
come on let's keep going keep going make
it louder come on
hello fate makers and vault hunters
happy packs
it is so great to see everybody back i
can't believe we're on stage again after
two
i love you guys you're fantastic
it is it is incredible and to feel the
energy and positivity in this room
almost calms my nerves and the
butterflies that are in my stomach so
just bear with me if we're a little bit
dusty we're working off some of the
cobwebs from uh not presenting in a
couple years uh but it's been a lot of
work uh what we've been doing both for
this panel and what we did on the booth
has anyone seen the booth yet
perfect
your love and some more support mean
everything to me and everyone at gearbox
and we have been here all week uh making
sure that we bring you a little bit of
joy and happiness today
now while
i and my team and everyone at gearbox
has been working today uh there is one
person
whose birthday it is today and i know it
sucks to work on your birthday but
sometimes you have to do it
and sometimes you especially have to do
it if your name is randy pitchford
now
[Applause]
i don't want to embarrass him and you
all don't want to hear me sing but let's
do this randy can i get you on stage
get out here randy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so let me say
let me say today is randy's 51st
birthday what
what'd you have to say that why'd you
have to tell him how old i am i like to
live on the edge
so this is a man who has committed his
entire life to entertaining the world he
wakes up
every single morning thinking about how
he can increase the amount of joy and
happiness that's out there and how we
can help entertain you so can we give
him one more round of applause for happy
birthday
[Applause]
thank you guys
thank you dan
well it's i got to be honest it's
i'm kind of frankly i'm kind of [ __ ]
up like it's hard
it's hard for me to like take praise
like i just want to make people feel
good and stuff so it's hard i can't even
accept birthdays i'm the worst um
uh
you got
thank you
you know what is that you know what i'm
gonna i've got this
i think it's on here i'll do this now
i'm gonna be back later you guys but
yeah okay so uh here let me
there's a chalkboard
i got some
some good anybody playing wonderlands
[Applause]
so here's some good
news this is the shift code
write it down
[Laughter]
ten skeleton keys
it's the first time we've done that so
yeah that's
my gift to you guys so i'll be back i'll
be back thank you
thank you randy cheers
what i love about that is he said write
it down and everybody lifted up their
phone to take a picture
that's what was awesome
all right so as i mentioned we haven't
been on stage in over two years we
haven't seen you guys uh we've missed
you all i hope you missed us
uh the past two years has been
tough if i'm gonna be honest with you
guys uh we have shipped some remarkable
content there was some great dlc for
borderlands 3.
there was some great games being
released in tribes and midgard uh we did
have the early access release of have a
nice death which is kind of amazing if
you haven't played it please yes if you
haven't played it please do godfall has
been incredible and just keeps getting
better and better and better uh
that's right and there's tiny tina's
wonderlands
[Music]
which there we go but we did all of this
while we tried to deal with a pandemic
worry about our families learn how to
work from home
some of you
may have experienced the same loss that
we did if you've lost family members to
covid
i don't know if you all follow the news
texas basically froze the hell over
last winter
we had team members that were literally
staying in each other's homes
to help support each other and we really
grew together as a gearbox family we
also expanded that gearbox family
i you all know that we've got a great
team up in quebec city
and we've got a great team in frisco
but we've expanded now to a new studio
in montreal
there we go
and
i love this so the team up in montreal
was working on some great games and as
much as i would love to talk to you
about what they're working on
i would super get fired
and i would like to be able to have a
job as soon as we leave here
but
some of you may have seen the news
gearbox is also expanding uh as of today
i put out the press release this morning
gearbox acquired lost boys interactive
now some of you may know lost boys
they helped us work on wonderlands
they also did a lot of work on call of
duty and pub g they're an incredible
team that is based in austin and they
have another studio up north uh and
we're so part so happy to have them be
part of the gearbox family now
looking ahead of as to what we've got
going on beyond just lost boys uh we
have and i apologize
uh my notes have completely gone from
the monitor and so now i'm just
completely vamping while i pray to god
that they come back quickly
so
before that oh wait throw their back
great uh
lost boys great team don't get fired you
like your job yes all right perfect uh
so but steve gibson who many of you know
uh is the president of gearbox
publishing is going to come on stage in
a little bit talk about some of uh
additional great talent and some
firepower that we've added to
uh to gearbox now we've got lots to talk
about today we do have some news that we
want to share with you that we're very
excited about
uh but
we realize we haven't seen like i said
we haven't seen you guys we want to
celebrate the community
everything that we do we do for you and
we hope and we love the feedback that
you give us
but today we want to celebrate the work
of our storytellers our artists our
innovators and really talk about what's
been great about borderlands let's talk
about that franchise let's talk about
wonderlands we're going to have some of
the developers up here on stage and we
really want to come together and
celebrate the community that we have all
built together uh and this moment at pax
now
i do have a favor to ask
many of the people who are going to be
on stage today have never spoken to an
audience this large
so some folks may stumble their words
some folks may seem a little bit nervous
can you please do me a favor and return
that nervousness with an energy of love
and let them hear how much you support
them that would be fantastic
so with that
i will be back on later
uh but i want to bring this stage a very
good friend of mine the president of
gearbox publishing
steve gibson
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody
i
am excited to be in front of you guys
once again it's been a couple years
um i know we have some amazing game
makers coming out here to talk and i've
got at least a few of you like you know
what i want i want to hear from somebody
who doesn't make games
this is your lucky day
so hi as i mentioned i'm steve gibson um
a few things to talk to you guys about
so our mission
is to be let's just call it the most
developer friendly publisher in the
world
we're doing our best for that today
we're going to talk to you about a
little about the things we're doing in
service of that we're going to talk to
you mostly about some of the smaller
games we're doing and imagine one day
we're going to be talking about some of
the bigger games that we're doing also
you'll hear from steve jones a little
later so
real quick what have we been up to and
what games do we have come for you guys
to see
first we have expanded
we welcome gearbox publishing san
francisco to the room
they in fact have a couple games i'm
gonna show you guys today
what else have we done we have added a
cryptic studios
they are working on multiple mmo games
that have been in the world for a long
time star trek neverwinter are the huge
games we're really excited welcome to
the family
and we're not done we've also added
another studio
gearbox publishing out in amsterdam
yes
i will be visiting there a lot
so um tell you what let me show you guys
first
one of the new games from gearbox
probably in san francisco take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we think you guys are going to love that
and actually we have another one to show
you we actually just launched this in
the early access just have a nice death
and there's a new update coming next
week have a look at this too
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so those are the first two games in our
uh gearbox publishing san francisco's
office as a reminder have a nice death
actually just launched into early access
you can go check it out right now on
steam there's more coming on that
i want to talk to you guys actually
about the one of the last games we
brought here to pax east
long time ago and we debate debuted them
here on stage and launched them that's
risk of rain too
[Applause]
we have just recently launched the
survivors of the void expansion pack
with them you can check that out on pc
and actually just now we've added them
to the epic game store take a look at
either one of those really really
excited about how this has gone for
everyone you're welcome to come play
with us there's a lot of players out
there playing right now
and we are planning even more content
going forward with the team at hope and
gearbox
all right more games
tribes of mid card
this also went really well for us really
really excited to work for the team uh
based out of montreal north fell studio
and in fact we have a cute little video
to show you
maybe not with audio though that was it
[Laughter]
yes
we did that that was great um so
more on that coming as well uh as you
can imagine we haven't uh you know
launched the season and we're doing more
seasons or and that is going really well
we have more updates for you guys later
on this year
we have more games
also godfall has gone great we have uh
launched it now onto xbox and onto steam
really really excited about that's
finally in the hands of a heck of a lot
of players as well uh
take a look
if you love looter shooters you'll
probably like looter slashers it is
going great and take a look on today on
xbox steam playstation egs you name it
we're there
all right what else we got
well yeah that's the thing i just
announced go go fast go
hey they want to see the game makers i
get it so now uh we do have one more
thing to talk to you about though and
that is a franchise it is an honor to be
associated with
now for here today i'm only going to
talk to you about a thing that a lot of
the hardcore fans are really excited
about and that is the collector's
edition
we have finally got this thing put
together
this is a huge responsibility this
franchise
is
beloved
and we want to get this right we are so
thankful our friends at idea planet down
in texas actually help us get this done
just right it's actually going to be
finally going up for pre-order and all
the major retailers that you can imagine
and
take a look we'll have more news on
homeworld a little later this year i
think you'll be excited to hear about it
also everybody here has phones right so
we're doing it
so we're going to do also homeworld
mobile
i have great news for you also uh we're
going to finally be able to launch
worldwide homeworld mobile actually
coming and i believe would we put up
there q4 this fall we're going to go
with this fall
so homeworld mobile
is
shockingly uh authentic feeling to the
franchise working closely with all the
franchise creators working closely with
blackboard and actually them giving us
plenty of ice the stratosphere team uh
has been amazing
when you play this you will feel like
you are in that homeworld universe it is
fantastic i look forward to you checking
it out
it'll be great
now uh a couple of small things that we
have done actually this one's very big
for us
um part of my language uh the
[ __ ] answer bundle um
so
really proud to announce we raised over
800 thousand dollars on that bundle to
[ __ ] concert cancer over that's been
great
okay
because indeed [ __ ] cancer
now uh a couple more partnerships we
want to show you guys
first is
relic hunters legends
[Applause]
you can do it
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
you guys want to move on to the next one
we'll try this at the end
you got it
okay
all right
so
uh we're going to show you a four-player
um
top-down
co-op looter
these are things that we know we all
love to play
oh geez
uh-oh
i
i you got me i i have a lot of
experience when videos break you during
it
was anybody here and uh when we
announced borderlands 3
wasn't that crazy yeah i'm like no play
it again
we gotta get it right
so let me tell you about this thing uh
you guys just yell at me when we're
ready but um this game that he's about
to that steve's about to show you like i
i got a
gosh about a year and a half ago yeah
when uh hey randy check this out
and i just went [ __ ] nuts for this
game like i went in the tank i was
playing it for like i don't know
probably 40 hours straight just like
this is amazing uh a lot of hours it was
it was
it's really fun uh so
like don't let steve's mild-mannered
kind of attitude take away the hype
because this freaking game is gonna be
it's gonna like you thought risk of rain
too surprised everybody this game's
gonna blow people's minds and it looks
humble and it looks chill but it is the
funnest thing i've played in a long time
steve thank you cue up the video
[Music]
hi facts this is lucy and leli and we
are community managers at vlogsdale a
ninja studio from brazil
it's such an honor for us to be here
today we're super fans of gearbox
especially borderlands pax has always
been in a special event for us in fact
this is where we met gearbox and start
working together two years ago and now
we can finally announce it to the whole
world gearbox and rogue are working
together on radiky hunter's legend
we heard some of you might like shooting
games and you don't mind if there's ludi
involved relicky hunter's legend is a
game about shooting looting and having
fun with friends and experience a story
about friendship time travel and
rambling against an evil empire
as a brazilian team just being here is a
great achievement for ourselves and the
latino community
we are so happy to tell our stories and
build this game just like a dream
[Applause]
well there's a lot more to tell about
the gamer for the coming months so we
hope you'll join us for the ride see you
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
it's my turn to break a video that was
great thank you um
okay
so uh
i hope you guys like that as randy told
you uh we fell in love with that game we
have been playing it so damn much uh we
cannot wait for everyone to get their
hands on it
and we have one more to show you
and actually we have an introduction to
the developer as well i want you to take
a look at this
new game coming from gearbox publishing
and partnership
it is
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is vladimir i'm the
director at under the stairs and what
you just saw was the trailer for our
debut game eyes in the dark
we're a small indie studio of seven
people based in zagreb croatia and we
come from all sorts of different
backgrounds
our programmer is a stand-up comedian
our game designer is an architect that
makes board games and i myself used to
have a djing career
eyes in the dark is our very first game
and getting a chance to showcase it to
so many people right now is
a little bit scary and crazy and weird
sort of like the game itself
we've been working on it on and off for
more than five years and during that
time we went through lots of ups and
downs in the face of covid and
earthquakes it sometimes felt silly to
be working on a video game but with
everything as it is right now we felt
the world needed a bit more light and
joy
speaking of light
eyes in the dark is a rogue light
platformer starring victoria bloom
victoria is a little girl who visits her
grandfather and finds that his mansion
has been overrun by a mysterious
darkness
as you explore blue manor you'll
encounter many crazy and unique items
and contraptions left behind by
victoria's eccentric family
victoria uses tinkerings to combine and
mix items in ways that create powerful
and crazy synergies
those synergies will in turn help you
defeat the biggest past monsters and
hopefully find and save grandpa
the team at gearbox publishing has been
absolutely incredible and they've helped
us every single step of the way
i can't tell you how much that kind of
support means to a small studio that is
just starting out
eyes in the dark will be launching on
steam and epic game store with
pre-orders open now
plus
if you pre-order you'll get a free copy
of the game's awesome soundtrack when we
launch on july 14th
and now that i've said it the release
date is pretty close and i just realized
i need to stop talking and get back to
work
thank you all again so much for watching
we'll have a lot more to share in the
coming months and we hope that you will
keep your eyes on eyes in the dark
bye
[Applause]
well then
uh i think we covered a whole lot of
games
i'm really really really honored that
many of these developers have chosen to
to work with us
we are in service of the game makers and
we are about to hear from plenty of them
coming up next after me thank you for
listening to me um and i want to welcome
back
our chief game maker randy pitchford
randy
[Applause]
[Music]
buddy
i'm so proud of that guy
you know when we uh holy crap we're at
pax
[Applause]
it was uh i was in the lobby on the last
day of pax
in 2020 when we decided that we had to
pull out of gdc and that we wouldn't be
going to e3 because of the pandemic
and like
it's just so great to see you guys
it's so awesome to be here and you guys
are on the vanguard you know like you
can tell there's like we're here there's
some people here but not everybody's
here on the show floor
uh your you being here and your support
will bring all the all the developers
back and all this all the companies back
and together we'll like we'll bring this
back baby
[Applause]
i'm uh
i'm so stoked steve gibson is like
killing it you know we we we've always
been i remember when we started gearbox
just you know a handful of friends of
mine and i we founded the company and
you know we always had to fight uh as
underdogs just to get anything done just
just to get any attention just to just
to make anything and find a way to a
customer with it and um
we we pledged when when with steve when
we started gearbox publishing that we
wanted to be the most developer friendly
publisher on the planet that we wanted
to be the publisher for
like new developers people taking risks
doing really cool fun stuff we wanted to
be the publisher that we always wished
existed for us
and uh i'm just like look at all the
cool stuff that they're doing like
that's so that's so great and you know
gearbox is growing of course um we we've
got we'll talk i'll talk a bit later
about gearbox studios we got gearbox
software um right now though
uh i know that there's a lot of people
here because you guys are playing
wonderland is that true some of you play
wonderland
and uh i thought we should talk about
wonderland uh for a minute and i wanted
to introduce like look the team is
amazing massive incredible group of
people that we all just killed ourselves
during this pandemic to make this game
and i wanted to introduce you to some of
the leadership from the wonderlands team
so let's uh let's welcome creative
director matt cox
producer caleb elmore
and uh your own lead writer sam winkler
sam buddy
[Applause]
and what do you guys got there you're
all drinking uh this is the delicious
flavor of brand synergy
that's you you're you're doing it yeah
the wonderland's g fuel the wonder
wonderland's g fuel are you guys here
time are you guys really hooped up yeah
are you are you are you yeah we chugged
like half of this in the last like two
minutes so this is gonna be a real
interesting segment you guys can see
ghosts too right
[Laughter]
but uh no uh it's been uh quite an honor
to release this game honestly like uh
our team
has worked incredibly hard over the last
two years it's been incredibly wonderful
to see
uh the response and all of our amazing
fans like this community is one of it's
the best community in the world like we
love borderlands and wonderland's fans
so give yourselves a hand we love you
guys
now matt
i feel like
part of the crucial wonderlands
experience is missing on this stage part
of the ecosystem i know you know what i
mean i do i think we need
a shroomie up here
let's bring assure me out on stage
come on out here
you guys did not
[Music]
oh i can't even
and uh from the back let me just tell
you it is screen accurate
uh
come on turn around turn around can you
turn around for us
can you do a three
six yeah a little peak
[Applause]
it's what they want
uh yeah and coincidentally uh the
shroomy butt is what got us the partial
nudity part of our teen
that is a true story part of the cover
canon
at least uh a i would say a week or two
of my life was spending time having very
real very adult conversations about that
but very official emails going back and
forth to every agency
across the globe to get that booty in
the game
oh my god but like we said we absolutely
love shrewmy first of all
it's amazing it's nice being the least
interesting thing yeah it's like yeah
yeah let's
uh but one of the most amazing
statistics just in the first month of
wonderland's release is that up to 28
of people who have played wonderland so
far have never played a borderlands game
before
so when we say that we want to entertain
the world we want to bring our style of
games to the entire world and so we are
expanding this community even greater so
uh we love you guys so much and there's
so many statistics out there that are
just kind of crazy just in the first
month we've had 275 million seaworks
killed 2.2 billion wyverns 2.3 billion
crabs killed and 4.5 billion skeletons
killed so if like their average height
was like five six you could stack
skeletons to the moon and back ten times
over
no it's a lot of stuff and and one of
the big things in uh in our game that we
tried to like
to introduce well we did introduce are
spells and melee and so there have been
2.6 billion spell kills 2.4 billion
melee kills two billion ground slams
like you can actually ground slam at
jump height and so apparently that's
happened two billion times that's
incredible um yeah there's there's just
so so many other things like half of all
grave borns uh failed monk school uh
many of our savo manches and sport
wardens were raised by elves uh and then
clawbringers and berserkers
overwhelmingly they're village idiots
i'm a clawbringer maine by the way
anybody else clawbringer in here yeah
nice buffs today by the way with the day
30 patch
so yeah what else do we got we had some
more didn't we oh yeah of course with
the overworld brand new brand new way to
traverse the entire wonderlands 1
billion dungeons were cleared 2 billion
encounters were cleared and of course
6.8 billion guns spells and weapons were
looted 4.7 billion pieces of gear looted
so you have played a ton of wonderlands
and of course 2 billion mimics and uh we
actually uh you know we also had a
character creator as well and and how
many how many of you have been having a
lot of fun with the character creator
yeah
so
we weren't able to focus on all of them
today but we did add a few from the
community of this wonderful character
creator and i can't thank the art teams
the design teams uh tech animation it
took an entire studio to get all of this
together and we're just so proud of the
team
look at that look at that guy
right here i want to meet the dude that
made that one
it looks like he just chugged this
[Laughter]
and amazingly uh this almost didn't come
to be we did not originally have a plan
to have an overdrive mode and it was one
of those things in a meeting we were
walking around one day and just like man
wouldn't it be cool to have one eyeball
huge and one eyeball tiny and we put the
slider in and the ui team uh made it
happen for us and now you can make your
very own monster and live that nightmare
it's been incredible and and we would be
remiss to not mention like we do have
such an incredible team of so many
developers design art code ui like and
all of the support like so many so many
people have poured their heart out uh to
make this game uh over the last several
years but uh and we also had a big
launch party yeah uh we were able to
celebrate the release in person which
was amazing cage the elephant played uh
we got to honestly see a lot of our
fellow devs in person for the first time
in a while uh i don't i don't know how i
haven't changed my clothes yeah
he hasn't changed
we've kept him in storage in cryogenic
uh we only unfreeze him for shows
most of wonderland uh was developed
remotely at home uh it has been an
interesting challenge but honestly uh i
think it really really shows in the
final product just how much uh every dev
who worked on this loved this game and
loved working on it so thank you all for
playing this game that meant so much to
us for the last few years
thank you guys
and thank you shroomie
and of course today uh our the first of
our season pass content dropped so why
don't you guys check this out
the coiled looked into the eyes of a god
and blinded him believing that this act
made them equals
but there is no equality between captors
and their captives
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
but one thing is certain
allowing a single being to live without
freedom makes monsters of us all
or freedom
is the only thing that can truly show
you who you are
[Laughter]
[Music]
so once again thank all of you for
coming out and those watching at homes
for the supports and just the love that
we're feeling today we make games
because we want to bring y'all joy and
cosplayers in the front i see you
yeah so just one more time hype it up
for yourselves hype it up for our
developers back in dallas and all around
the world and hype it up for you right
here today
thank you guys
true me say goodbye thank you shrumi
thank you guys
not a high visibility situation
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
it's so crazy working on
video games because it's all digital
it's all
fake and then like something happens in
the real world and my mind blows when i
when i see like the cosplayers here like
my mind just explodes
one of the other cool things that
happens is sometimes there's other folks
that actually make things in the real
world and they like they like some of
the stuff we're doing so they end up
like hey what if we made uh like
this g-fuel one like wonderland's g like
what is this why does that exist and yet
it's happening and uh there's this
awesome person at gearbox who kind of
interacts with all these people and
these companies and and make sure that
all this cool stuff happens and i'm
talking about like everything from
action figures to t-shirts and hats and
all that cool stuff and uh let's bring
her out to tell us about all the cool
stuff going on uh erica
this is erica steed
i'm just gonna leave the stage for you
i'll be back
hey pax in real life
i don't know what to do with my hands um
it's been a little while but we are all
friends here right i'm looking out here
[Music]
i see a lot of familiar faces i see some
of you i've seen it show after show
and if this is your first time like it's
okay we're friends now buddy
so i have been at gearbox
for about eight years and i have got to
meet people like you at shows and events
all over the world and it has been a big
crazy ride and i feel like all of you
have been on that ride with us
but for the past couple of years me
i've been pretty much nowhere
the product though that my team and i
have been working on that has been all
over the world so as gearbox has grown
we have really tried to push to go
beyond what we've done before and part
of that means having more partnerships
in places that we have not been in
before
so right now for example in asia we have
a collection with super groupies in
japan
we also have our figures with mighty
jags who are based in singapore
in europe we have emp bringing apparel
straight to germany
we have also just announced our
valentine's moxie branded scotch
[Applause]
are you guys into that
[Applause]
all right i'm noting it down that is
available right now in europe and
several other territories around the
world
we also have out of the uk laced records
they are bringing our soundtracks to
your turntable and or digital devices
all around the world wherever you are
[Applause]
and we also have ventured into some
different categories some different
products that we haven't done before
like for example did you know that we
have our own tiny tina's wonderland's
energy drink with our partners at g-fuel
[Applause]
now our booth today is also powered by g
fuel just saying
so we've also recently come out with
this awesome controller from power a
[Music]
now i know a controller is not really
that surprising you guys probably
expected that from us but to be honest i
like this controller and i wanted to
show it to you so please look at this
controller
[Music]
[Applause]
now we've also been pushing to expand
our ips in other ways and to go deeper
and explore our ieps in
different meaningful ways now one of our
biggest partners on that front has been
dark horse
i like them too
and so we've been working with them
quietly for about two years and recently
they've also joined us as part of the
embracer family so we are so happy to
have them in the family and we really
look forward to what we can all do
together in the future but for today
let's take a little peek at some of the
things we've been working on so far
so we have our first borderlands lore
book this
this has been a huge project for my team
and also for the dark horse team
and we are putting the finishing touches
on this right now but it has been a lot
of fun just digging through the archives
going deep into old lore images assets
putting it all together to weave it into
a story for all of you guys
now we will be announcing a making a
release announcement for this sometime
soon very soon so stand by for that
i also want to talk to you about two
different comic book projects that we
have coming up
so
yeah go go on applaud it's fine
so they're actually there there is one
of these projects it is a very
fantabulous project but i actually
cannot talk to you about it today
pr guys am i right um
but i can reveal
our brand new borderlands comic book
series with writer amy chu and amy chu
is actually in the audience today amy
where are you she's right here
applaud applaud
welcome to the border fam
so she has been hard at work writing the
original story for this new series and
of course we are all sworn to secrecy
but i've read it and i think you guys
are really going to like it and i look
forward to telling you all more about
this as the time is right
but i do have to tell you a couple more
things that are happening right here and
now today
so we have been working on improving our
gearbox store both online at
gearboxloot.com and also today in the
booth on the show floor
so on the website we've just put up some
new product from all of our ips you can
shop that right now
down on the show floor we're doing a
little bit of a sample sale so we have
taken all of the things out of our vault
brought them here put them out for you
to shop take home love forever
so this is a good chance for you to get
if there is a past item that you missed
out on
and we have some really rare things
we've brought down here and we also have
a few things that have never been sold
before in this country so come on down
to the booth dig through all the stuff
get the good stuff before anybody else
does
so if you are watching from home right
now i know you're probably a little
bummed that i'm talking about things
that you can't come out and see
but i don't want you to feel like you've
missed out so we did do a discount code
for the website just for you
discount code everyone write this down
get a discount
i like it when you guys applaud
this is why we're friends all right
but i have to tell you about one more
thing today and in all seriousness this
is a big one for me
this was one of the first dreams that i
learned of when i started at gearbox and
over time this became my dream as well
we wanted to create a real life tabletop
bunkers and badasses role playing game
but
we wanted to do a really good job we
wanted you to really feel like you were
stepping into the same adventure that
tiny tina and her friends sat down to in
an assault on dragon keep
and we wanted to take this thing all the
way or we didn't want to go at all and i
am happy to announce that with our
partners and good friends at nirvana
games
that bunkers and badasses dream is now
you may apply
but seriously there is somebody else at
gearbox who has dreamed of this for
longer than i have and
i know he's been waiting for this day so
it would only be right to bring him back
out to show it off for you especially
because today is his birthday
randy
thank you erica
thank you happy birthday thank you
oh my god so like you know we're nerds
huge
nerds
and uh
this this is real this you saw me
carrying this around earlier this is the
bunkers and badass the source book
you've got one right there um you can
you can get this now it's a real thing
thanks to uh
all the all the amazing people at
nirvana games this now exists and i
thought i'd unbox it for you um i don't
know if you guys uh have seen what's
inside but this is this is the deluxe
edition you can buy just the book
but you can also get the deluxe edition
which comes with some super cool stuff
so i just wanted to quickly show you
what's inside
and then
and then i thought you know since uh
there's probably some cool stuff inside
um i thought maybe maybe we could do
something with the the objects
um
so first you've got like these are punch
out enemies
there's the source book of course
uh there's a dm screen you know or sorry
bm screen not battle movement
bunker master screen which uh not only
protects uh all of the secret stuff that
bunker masters do but includes look at
all that there's like tape like look up
tables like super nerdy stuff that's
like the stuff of dreams and then look
at this there's the miniatures um and
tina's written all over it this is her
copy you're getting so she writes my
friends and you can see all the
miniatures and there's the uh the dice
and uh and there's a giant d20 that's as
big as your fist she calls it the big
boy um
and uh yeah and we're gonna dump here
let me dump these out here um i thought
and there's so much other cool stuff in
here there's a play mat you even get a
custom um
uh uh dry erase marker with the bunkers
and badasses logo on it um i thought
wouldn't it be cool to do uh to do you
know it's kind of become a tradition at
pax for me to try to
do a magic trick with the stuff so
so
here's here's here's the thing when i
was when i don't know how this started
but when i was young and i used to play
dungeons and dragons with my friends i
sort of discovered that i had this crazy
uncanny ability to always know exactly
which characters
the the party the people in the party
would pick right and and it didn't
matter if they were my oldest friends or
people that had just come because a
friend of a friend knew them and they're
just joining our party that night i
could always know and it didn't matter
if they were picking like the class like
like oh i can always tell oh you're
going to be a cleric for sure um and or
or if they're actually taking one of the
pre-rolled characters or with name
personalities i always just knew exactly
who was going to pick who and uh and i
haven't i mean it became a game you know
people put money on it where it was like
betting what can randy nail everybody's
choices and i got really good at it and
i haven't done this in a long time but i
thought i'd try it tonight with the
bunkers and badasses characters and to
make it super hard i thought i would do
it with people that i have never met
before complete strangers from the
audience and uh we're gonna have to pick
randomly from the audience
but look this is bunkers and badasses so
i'm not just gonna pick on you because
then you'll believe that i picked
somebody that was a plant we're gonna do
the super random we're gonna roll
initiative can we get some dice out here
all right
so i'm gonna throw this is a giant
inflatable d20 i'm gonna throw it out
into the audience just let it bounce
around we're gonna place the music we're
actually gonna get three volunteers okay
so i'm gonna throw this one out that
direction
catch it catch it catch it throw it
around throw it up
[Music]
oh the music stopped who's got it who's
got it who's got it
who's got it stand up if you've got one
of the dice stand up
all right uh can you each come forward
how do we get them on stage there's no
st can somebody help uh who are you
gonna help me somebody can can somebody
help me get these people on stage come
to the front here come to the front
thanks you guys are there stairs
anywhere oh he's gonna yeah come to the
front we're gonna get you guys on stage
uh and you're gonna you're gonna be my
helpers uh let's give it up for them
it's gonna take them just a second to
get on stage but yeah we got we got
three volunteers
uh and um in order to do this to make
this fair
um we need a uh we need a bunker master
um so uh i've actually got one of our
cosplayer friends
uh uh we got tiny tina who's a better
bunker mask than tiny tina come on out
wow that's an incredible so remind me
your name again
casey that's right casey you're this is
an incredible costume now we have met
before we right when was the first time
we met um i think it was 2019. 2019 it
was at a pax or was it somewhere else it
was packs
that's right when we announced
borderlands 3 you were there i think you
made the the
the head the the hat right yeah that's
right so this is an incredible
wonderland's tiny tina absolutely
incredible now
thanks for helping out with this for
being our bunker master um
we didn't set anything up though in
advance for this you had no idea this
was gonna happen you didn't know
anything about this your job you are the
referee for the you are the bunker
master because um hey come on up you you
guys yeah yeah yeah yeah no this is fine
yeah let's get let's yeah yeah right
here we're in a line yeah yeah we can go
around this way that's okay perfect
perfect so nice to meet you guys welcome
don't be intimidated
like right here let's like stand here
and here and here and we'll figure it
out
perfect
hi so nice to meet you guys we're going
to get to you in just a second um in
fact here let's fix this a little bit i
want each of you to roll
because we got to roll for initiative to
figure out who's going to go first okay
so just you know spin it and let it fall
in front of you yeah there you go let it
fall in front of you don't cheat okay
everybody you keep an eye on them don't
make sure they don't cheat okay so um oh
tina's gonna watch yeah let's do it roll
for initiative you guys
okay wow
okay don't don't don't move it's fine
this will work um and tina you're gonna
be our
let me get i got the miniatures out
already you're gonna be um our uh
about here hold that hold on to the dm
screen for a minute i don't want to
forget this so let me just i'm just
gonna use this chalkboard again is it
did you guys get the shift code already
did you guys get that okay i'm gonna
it's gone now so
all right so what did we what did we got
here we rolled
we rolled uh a nine is the highest the
nine is the highest
okay so nine and what's next two
and we've got a one
okay so nine two and one and i don't
wanna forget your names so uh what
what's your name
laura l-a-r-a or
l-a okay
okay and number two what what's your
name
brent bryant bryant with a wire and i
bryant
and you are
tyler that's okay
everybody can be named whatever they're
named it's there's no there's no
judgement here okay um
tyler
okay laura bryant and tyler okay um
thanks um
when i write things down i just always
remember okay so we're gonna go in order
uh you're gonna protect i can't see what
they're choosing so i want you to take
the uh take the bm screen and protect
protect the uh
um let me make sure we got the the rules
did i leave where did i leave my book
um
and i'm gonna stand way over here okay
um you uh who's first you're going to go
first look at the characters um and just
take one of the miniatures and hold it
in your hand so that nobody knows but
you so pick one of the miniatures and
you're going to pick from any any of the
vault hunters that are up there the
miniatures and just hold it in your hand
so nobody knows about you and
yeah you should know what it is
do you have it
grab one
do you have one
okay
and then um
[Music]
why don't um
what is it two is next you uh uh uh go
ahead you pick don't don't let me see i
don't wanna see
okay
okay you've got it
okay and then um
oh boy
uh
sorry who's next you're tyler your last
go ahead you pick you pick
okay we've got three choices
and i've got to figure out what they are
okay you picked first now you picked
first you're number nine
did you pick um
did you pick one of the men or one of
the you picked one of the men didn't you
one of the male characters i kind of
just grabbed one
do you know did you know the character
do you recognize the character
[Applause]
okay
this is really hard to get a read if i
and you picked you picked one of the men
didn't you i think so okay yeah um
and um
oh man you're you're a tough read where
are you from
maryland maryland
did
i think i think this did you pick zero
the robot sorry he's not a robot shoot
i'm so i'm i'm so bad what did you get
i'm sorry can i see what you got
oh you got brick okay look i'm i'm oh
for one you guys
i'm over one it's okay let me and you
got two let me see if i can get you next
what did you get um you got
you actually you also picked one of the
guys didn't you yes and you picked um
you didn't you picked the short dude no
did you
is it salvador did you did you get
salvador i'm o for two which one did you
get which one did you get you got roland
of course oh [ __ ] roland okay
i'm over two this is this is going so
poorly okay so
i thought we rolled the low number
i nailed you though i'm sure of it
well you didn't i was going to get it
you're going to let me guess
you picked the siren maya yes
of course you did you denied my my you
denied okay well look this is
i gotta tell you guys to be honest this
is not my skill i can't actu i lied to
you earlier i can't actually get a read
you know you you got you got um
you got um
uh uh you got brick
you got
um
uh
roland
and you got maya so brick roland and
maya
i i lied to you earlier i um i i
actually can't do this at all this is a
complete ruse
um in fact let me can i see i just want
to make sure so brick roland and maya
yeah
um this is a complete ruse the skill
that i have is not
the ability to get a read in fact that
threw me off
that threw me completely off the skill i
have
is
kind of seeing into the future
and earlier i lied i told you that when
i wrote the numbers on the chalkboard i
told you i was writing your names next
to it i didn't write your names at all i
actually actually wrote the characters
that you'd be picking
can you hold this for a second
no
no
are you ready for this you guys
brick
rolling
what just happened
thank you
thank you and you know what
for your help in this
um you each get a copy of bunkers and
bad asses
so
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you and
hey tina for helping out would you would
you um would you like to use this
version this this coffee that we've used
for this
you can have the you could have the demo
copy
all right let me get you all sorted here
um thank you guys uh can we get somebody
that let's give a big hand
to our helpers here can we get somebody
to help them off stage safely thanks you
guys thank you guys
let me get you sorted here
um don't don't leave tina oh she left
she's gone
it's okay it's okay i got it i'm gonna
put this back together for we'll take
over backstage
um
wow so one of the cool things here i'll
just bring this back with me when i go
um one of the cool things about gearbox
is we we've kind of been lucky over the
years and and we we've grown a lot and
um
we uh uh you know you met steve gibson
earlier who's the president of gearbox
publishing and a bit of i'll come out
and talk to you about some of the things
we're doing with gearbox studios making
films and stuff um uh but you know one
of the one of my proudest moments
there's a there's a guy that that i've
been working with since we founded the
company who's uh better frankly better
than me uh he's he's the best amongst us
and uh in order to you know help help me
be able to kind of focus more higher
level and build gearbox studios and and
spend more time with the creative on the
games uh it became very clear that we
needed better leadership than me for the
development part of our business gearbox
software and i want to introduce you to
this guy he's awesome he's one of the
greatest people i know
heart of gold pure integrity uh please
welcome the new president of gearbox
software steve jones
hey thank you everybody
thank you randy and thank you all for
such a warm warm welcome
as randy said i've been with gearbox 23
years this is actually my first time on
stage at event like this is truly
impressive
well thank you all for the support
so i think somebody went uh diving
through the gearbox photo archive for
that picture of me i think that was uh
year 2000 probably
goodness um
now my background's actually in
programming
and you know while i'm transitioning to
this new role i thought you know what
what better way to to give you a sense
of what i'm going to bring to gearbox
and to tell you a little bit about you
know where i come from and you know what
i've done so yeah programming in fact
there's a bunch of games from way back
that i spent a whole lot of time working
on
and now as much as i love programming
and i was doing it submitting code
basically right up until i transitioned
into this new role
it's not actually my favorite thing i do
you know what i've really really grown
to love is empowering the crazy creative
minds we have at gearbox
and i never had a bigger test than that
and when i was technical director on
borderlands one and two
now up until those games you know we
could basically just code up the dozen
or so weapons in a game a few enemies
and that was that
but the team that wanted to make
borderlands wanted bazillions of guns
dozens of character skills
different gear types you name it and
they all had to interact and do crazy
things
and that required a whole new way of
making games
and so you see here some of the tools we
came up with on those first two
borderlands games to make that possible
my goal then was to get i basically
directly tapped into the brains of our
creators remove all obstacles so they
could just express whatever crazy idea
they had straight on the game
and for all you borland's players out
there i think you can say we nailed it
because the day
there's the craziest things and it never
ceased to amaze me and in fact you've
remembered that first dlc we did for
borderlands 1 the zombie island of dr
ned you know that was
great dlc
came out right after
we launched the game like 30 days later
and there were no zombies in borderlands
one
and yet the team was able to with
basically the tools as rudimentary as
they were after that first game to just
make that
and then that is sort of why i always go
back to this example sort of the
pinnacle of what we were able to do with
that approach
now
looking ahead
as uh you know
we aspire to our mission of entertaining
the world we've got to make a lot more
games
different types of games like wonderland
which is reaching new audiences and to
do that we're going to need a lot more
help
you know we've got
developers that have been with gearbox
for some time stepping up into you know
project director roles for the first
time
and someday they'll be up on a stage
like this telling you about their games
and i cannot wait to see what that
team's going to do but that's not enough
so we're growing
think about what dan showed earlier
we've got the team in frisco it's
growing the team in quebec city is
growing and the new studio founded in
montreal all growing
i want to extend a very very special
welcome to the team at lost boys
interactive i'm thrilled to have you on
board and i can't wait to see what we're
going to do together
so
that's just a little hint of me i
fortunately all those games are coming
but none here yet
and one day we'll be up here to show you
those
so before we look at the rest of the
software lineup i want to bring back
randy to tell us a little bit about the
gearbox studios randy
[Applause]
[Music]
steve's such a steve is such a humble
dude but you know he's got now
like a thousand people working for him
all making video games
and uh
man if you knew what i knew about what's
coming it's so cool like he like when he
was saying someday those these guys are
going to be on stage talking about their
stuff uh it's it's really exciting stuff
one of the cool things that that i've
been able to spend some more of my time
on is the creation of gearbox studios
which is of course uh gearbox doing
transmedia and i think some of you may
have heard of one of the projects uh the
the borderlands movie uh some of you
might know that that's the thing
and uh of course you know we partnered
with uh lionsgate uh the awesome awesome
uh company that the studio that makes
brilliant stuff i don't know if any of
you guys enjoyed the hunger game movies
or twilight or you know some some some
recent cool stuff um like um uh uh
knives out and uh and and you you will
thank me later when you go see uh the
new nick cage movie um uh
the the what is it the the massive
the unbearable weight of massive talent
yeah it is
i got a chance to go see it at south by
southwest uh with nicholas cage
i'm kind of like a hollywood guy now
uh holy [ __ ] that movie blew me away
you're gonna love it um but they're a
great partner and of course erod
productions um you know avi ahrad
literally founded marvel studios
and uh they created the spider-man movie
and then they did you know x-men and
then iron man and then the avengers and
it's kind of gone well for them
uh the r odds were like yeah we figured
out how to make the largest
entertainment on the planet out of comic
books let's try video games and uh you
know ari and avi came to me thinking
borderlands would be the perfect
uh proof case and they're just awesome
people to work with and then this
incredible talent with eli roth
directing the film and unbelievable cast
kate blanchett
kevin hart
jack black
[Applause]
jamie lee curtis like
legendary legendary gina gershon is
moxie
can you believe that like it's
ridiculous
um and uh it's we're in post-production
right now and uh it's going well and uh
you don't lionsgate will tell you when
the movie's ready now in addition to the
borderlands movie of course gearbox has
some other really exciting properties
like homeworld and brothers in arms and
duke nukem and we have development
action with all of these properties and
we'll be announcing some things some
announcements very big and exciting
announcements will be coming
uh
sooner than later very very soon in fact
uh it's been a thrill to
find ways to take these characters and
these universes that we care so much
about and bring them to new mediums
because if you're like me
you love playing video games but there
are people in your lives you'd like to
share this stuff with that aren't
necessarily going to sit down with you
and play borderlands for 40 hours
and now i could bring other people in my
family to the movie theater and share
this awesome universe with them and i i
hope that's what some of you guys do and
i hope you have a fun time doing it
thanks um
awesome thank you
uh let's see um
uh moving on what do we got next
oh yeah you know what this i was talking
about the borderlands movie um and uh
there's still stuff going on with
borderlands borderlands 3 and uh and i
wanted to um i wanted to talk about i
wanted to share with you uh some of the
awesome talent that's been keeping
borderlands 3 alive um the the people
you're about to meet um
mario's producer graham is a designer
and a creative director and these guys i
mean graham and i have been working on
borderlands since the very very
beginning and graham and even before
that graham and i have been working
since brothers in arms on on on these
games and they have done some awesome
and incredible work so please welcome to
the stage mario and graham
[Applause]
and i'll leave i'm going to leave the
stage to you you guys are all alone
hi awesome hi everyone
how's everyone doing
uh my name is mario rodriguez and i'm
producer of live ops i'm graham timmons
i'm the creative director on borderlands
3.
cool so yeah as you all know we've been
working on borderlands 3 for almost over
two and a half years um so we've done a
lot of stuff
um up here we have an awesome image
created by one of our community members
pyrek that summarizes everything that
we've done these past two and a half
years everything from six dlcs 21
patches
lots of free content and thousands and
thousands of hot fixes
so graham tell us a little bit about
dlcs so yeah over the course of
borderlands 3 we have released six dlcs
and that's like a whole another game's
worth of content we're
extremely proud of the reception and i'm
extremely proud of our team have been
able to consistently deliver
really fantastic stuff to our community
and obviously you guys have really
received it incredibly well so thank you
um you know that's tons of new gear new
places to go new things to kill
and that's just the dlc's we also have
released tons of free content to the
community over the course of these last
two and a half years uh things like the
takedowns the true trials mode
tons of gear and both of those that you
can get
so we've you know continued to expand
borderlands 3 from day one and we're
just thankful that all of you guys came
along for the ride
[Applause]
like you said
after all the content we've also done
weekly events
such as
loot the universe may have mild and take
down showdown and more
but we also wanted to talk about
everything you guys have done so we have
a few stats
for you guys as well
uh so yeah you guys are cash hoarders
you've collected over a quadrillion i
think that's the right number uh amount
of cash uh along your way
and you guys have been very generous
with moxie and have donated over 52
billion worth of tips she's a
billionaire now he's a billionaire
uh so yeah and obviously you guys have
been looting things like chess but also
toilets and refrigerators and the
laundromats
43 billion uh items have been uh found
in lootables
and we know you guys like guns
and as a fact there's been
14.69 billion guns collected
overall
but let's also give it up to the ones
that are being left in the ground from
time to time yeah those are just the
collected ones
you know there's billions out there you
guys have just turned away from so a
moment of silence for them
uh anyway uh also as i said earlier you
guys like killing things that's really
fun in our game and uh fire element has
been by far the most popular element in
the game and there's been
uh 51 billion elemental kills and fire
has been the pop most popular
and lastly uh
we have taken down
46.97 billion children of the vault
so good job nice work guys
uh
awesome we also have this incredible
system shift that you guys have been
able to get shift codes uh to open uh
the diamond and golden uh key chest so
the golden chests have been opened 128
million times that's so much free loot
it kind of hurts the designer in me that
you guys are getting loot from a code
but
so be it so be it
and with the
final dlc the director's cut we released
the vault cards
which was a way for you to obtain a very
slim chance of obtaining diamond keys
so you can use those in the diamond loot
chest we also give away some for free
so we've had 8.79 million uh diamond
chests open
that's cool so it's been a lot it's been
a lot
but we're not done yet
yeah so we still have new events going
for borderlands 3. so i'm excited to
announce that in
the course of may we'll be doing the
maliwan mayhem event where each of these
maliwan bosses will be turned into raid
bosses once a week
their loot pools are going to change
they're going to do a lot more damage
hopefully a lot of you will die
if i did it right uh but you'll also get
a custo a new character-specific head
each week if you kill the community
challenge value for that week uh and
here's a hint of what that first head's
gonna look like
and finally
we have another big thing coming
you guys on platforms like epic steam
xbox games and series x series s and
stadia have been playing together
and ps4 and ps5 we're a little bit on
the side
well
we're very happy to announce that later
this spring
everything is coming together and you
all will be able to play with everyone
on the same game so
fast play full cosplay is coming
[Applause]
[Music]
so again
we thank you so much for playing this
game for over two and a half years it's
been an incredible journey um and we
hope you keep playing it so thanks
everyone thanks everyone
[Music]
thanks you guys thanks mario thanks
graham
uh
yeah i still play borderlands 3 i don't
know if any of you guys do too i gotta
confess i still do it um it's pretty uh
it's pretty stoked on that and i i know
many of you love the borderlands
universe and the stories told within it
we love it too
and
we also know that many of you loved
tales from the borderlands
right
well as you know uh some of the
characters from tales from the
borderlands made their way into
borderlands 3.
so we really love
that format as a way to create
characters and create new stories and
explore all of that differently than
what's possible with the looter shooter
games
because of the success and our love for
tales
and because of our interest in
developing the borderlands universe in
new ways
we thought it would be fun and exciting
to dive into the format of interactive
fiction once again
this time
we're doing it to imagine all new
characters and all new stories from the
borderlands
so soon we'll be announcing an entirely
new game set in the borderlands universe
and presented in that style of
interactive fiction
i'm talking about
an all new tales from the borderlands
adventure it's
[Applause]
it's going to be releasing this year
it's published by 2k games and it has
been developed in-house by gearbox
software and it has all new characters
and stories said in the borderlands
universe
we
thanks yeah we've been working on this
experience secretly for many years
and i can't wait until it's time to
announce this all new game this summer
and show all of you what we've been
doing so please be on the lookout this
summer for the announcement of an all
new tales from the borderlands
[Applause]
hey listen you guys are awesome uh i
think later i think after this i'm i'm
gonna go down with all the guys you saw
on stage and some other people that are
here from from gearbox and if anybody
wants to meet us uh if you want us to
sign any of your games or your books or
whatever we'll be down there um i don't
exactly know where that is but we'll be
doing that uh but it's it's been a
thrill to spend some time with you again
and be on the stage and i hope some of
you come down to say hi to us and uh i'm
gonna pass it back to dan hewitt who's
going to take us home dan hey everybody
so the good news is i do know where that
autograph signing is
so at four o'clock we're going to do
autograph signing at the back of the
queue hall so if you want to leave here
and head back to the queue hall we'll go
ahead and get you into that queue and
you can have randy and the entire dev
team sign whatever you would like
including the poster that was on that
you got on your way in if you didn't get
a poster come by the gearbox booth we've
got one for you if you're watching at
home
fomo's real i don't know what to tell
you i mean it just kind of it's one of
those things uh and come by the booth
which uh is being powered by our friends
at zydax and amd
and i certainly want to give an
incredible amount of thanks to our
publisher for the wonderlands and
borderlands series our friends at 2k
without whom we cannot be here today so
thank you 2k publishing
all right y'all let's go get em have a
great pax
thank you for coming